for the diamondbacks tonight the rookie
left-hander tyler gilbert he faced the
padres here at chase field three starts
ago and oh by the way through a
no-hitter he drew a no hitter he
actually had a relief appearance against
the padres before that went two innings
gave up only one hit in that so a
combined one hit in 11 innings of work
against the padres this year cronenworth
is the shortstop now with tontice
converted into an outfielder for the
time being
they have a chance to collect this one
third base side nick ahmed in foul
ground now it's manny machado version
still holding machado chased a fastball
up above the zone first strikeout for
tyler gilbert elevated fastballs well
above the top of the zone that time
that's a shoulder high fastball out of
the strike zone away and manny chased
two down and brings up fernando
grisham's in scoring position 1-2
and a breaking ball hit a long way to
deep left center field that ball is back
and it is gone
two run home run for fernando tatis
junior is 36 in the year and the padres
off to the fast start on top two nothing
good start in the desert for the friars
the diamondbacks were just a catch of
the baseball in the glove from getting
out of this inning but crushing mistakes
as we mentioned earlier the numbers
against the diamondbacks that's a
hanging breaking ball down and in yeah
down and in but still a hangar right to
the swing path of tatis junior big honey
for chris after coming off the il the
strained oblique during an bullpen
session maybe 60 70 pitches tonight for
chris paddock josh rojas who has been
hot
and a swing and a miss here in a pitch
in the dirt gets away briefly from nola
so he clears the rudder and throws out
rojas first strikeout of the night for
paddock oh it's a nice curveball right
there by chris patter can't get hurt
down there he bounced it that's exactly
where he wanted it gonna bring up ketel
marta one two is driven to right center
field and deep on the run is grisham
he'll get there good running catch by
trent grisham two down in the first
inning two two pitch coming up and he
goes to the breaking ball to strike out
smith and in the end a big curveball one
out runner at second it brings up austin
nola now one and two
through the right side into right field
to base hit they're gonna send myers
here comes the throw from smith and it
is off the mark and over everybody the
second base goes nola but a good throw
there and i think it really would have
been close and bobby dickerson sends
myers
pavin smith basically had the ball out
there in right field but the throw not
good and the padres taking three-nothing
leads well the big kid at second base
has got some speed
great hitting by nola once again going
the opposite way and that's total yard
sale throwing everything all over the
place here's grisham with first in third
and one down
the bunk bid and it's out towards walker
the throw first to be late in the run
scores in the back door comes austin
nola
with the fourth padres run of the night
so another bunt bid here and this one
was hard out towards second base it's a
base hit and an rbi for trent christian
trent grisham placed this ball perfectly
checks up
even even if gilbert as soon as that
ball is bunny goes over to first base i
think there's no chance of getting him
rojas out of the picture till late
the speed of grisham
no chance and the padres just opened it
up in this one earlier
myers at second base as you're trying to
bring in another friar's run right here
one two again a fraser
and this is under the glove of rojas off
of it coming around from second is myers
he will score in the padres take a
five-nothing lead he's hit and an rbi
for adam frazier and the padres looted
five-nothing a play that's not made that
starts adam frazier off on a tear
as we go into the end of august and
early september that's exactly what i'm
talking about if you're not going to be
stealing bases need some hits chalk up
another rbi
shadow at second with two outs
that's a bullet and what a stop by josh
van meter
got him
josh van meter they want to see what it
looks like at third look at this that
was a rocket whoa that saved a run right
there so jay's tingler goes to his
bullpen the alaska usa federal credit
union pitching change
it's the veteran chris stamen
got another solid season for the padres
73 in a third innings pitch he struck
out 70 walked only 12.
a sinker-cutter curveball combination
from the veteran craig stamin so here is
the rookie mccarthy marshall with third
omitted first and two outs
and kicks away from nola here comes far
show diamondbacks get on the board a
sinker from stamen sunk a little too
much
it almost looked like nola was caught by
surprise just kind of reached out there
tried to backhand that sinker in the
dirt
diamondbacks with a two-out rally going
here
batting with two down bases empty one
for three game for hosmer it's a fly
ball to deep right center field back
goes martay at the wall that ball is
gone
eric cosmer with home run number 11 of
the year and the padres take a 6-1 lead
solo shot for eric hosmer that's a big
run for the friars and that's a big
swing and judging by eric hosmer's
oppose after that he knew that he got it
but still it's that part of the ballpark
to where you know what you got to run
let's watch this one and a nice catch by
the fan there just above the yellow line
the ball got out in a hurry diamondbacks
with their best chance tonight to get
back in this ball game trailing the
padres six to one so now they're loaded
with two down for cattell marte
hits a fly ball deep to right field
hebso grand slam
could tell martay that's his ninth and
it's a one-run ball game oh we are told
he's a superstar and that's what
superstars do
a little cutter right in the middle of
the plate and down right where cattell
likes him barrels that ball to right
field you said it partner if they're
going to get back in this game they got
to do something right here to tell marty
must have heard you over the head of
tatis
making an 11-game hitting streak for
cattell in a six to five san diego lead
and who had a two-run home run in the
first inning machado at second one on to
one run game
a drive to center field and that ball is
going to be a one-hopper to the wall
around from second comes machado he will
score it's an rbi double for fernando
and the padres take a 7-5 lead there's
your insurance
thanks to fernando tatis jr good call
partner there's that run you were
talking about and that one just kind of
rolls over the outer third and fernando
gets extended
oh yeah that sound almost identical to
where manny spanked it trading places
with machado and another run
7-5 padres on top now two down in the
ninth inning and here is josh rojas for
three night with a walk and a run scored
on the ground right side frazier will go
to first and the padres win mark
malanson comes in to secure the save the
padres hold on and win this one seven to
five
you